this
is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio this
is the ramsey show it's where america is
hanging out to have a conversation about
life that's right the whole picture
we're talking money
talking your work talking your dreams
we're talking your relationships
and i'm thrilled to be with you along
with my colleague i am ken coleman host
of the ken coleman show
a part of the ramsey network and my
colleague dr john delaney host of the dr
john dolone show
you can tell that we put hours and hours
and hours and cents
into those names they're very creative
john there is nothing more uncomfortable
for me that's not true there's several
uncomfortable things for me but one
but please don't share constantly having
to refer to yourself
what you're right in the third person
right welcome to the king home show
welcome to dr john delaney
but see you've got a little extra thing
in front of you the doctor part yeah
that just makes it more
pretentious infinitely so and it just
makes it a tongue twister
and it's legit but i knew i know two
other dr daloni's my mom and my wife
yeah and they're way smarter than me
just doesn't sound that cool but i'll
take it
but yeah it'd be cool if the show is
called like i don't know
yeah well that [ __ ] is sailed it has it
has sailed
so we're here to help you we'll talk
about your money we'll talk about your
life uh let me tee this up every time
john and i are together we
love to take on toxicity and work
because i'm i'm focusing on that topic
from time to time on the ken coleman
show because people are unhappy in their
work many times john just because
of their leadership above them or
co-workers and toxicity can take someone
right out of feeling let's say it's
their dream job
and it can become a nightmare within a
matter of weeks when you're in a toxic
environment
uh and then we also take on hey
relationship stuff
around hey i feel like i'm supposed to
do this my spouse isn't on board
we take on a lot of that stuff so and
we're going to of course take on your
money questions and everything else as
well so we want to help you win
and john and i are here to help you
here's how we do it you get to dial in
it's a toll-free number triple eight
eight two five five two two five triple
eight
eight 825-5225
coming up next segment john we're going
to have some fun
so on the ken coleman show every once in
a while we do some funny work
fails because we humans need to laugh at
ourselves
and then when we can't laugh at
ourselves the next best thing is to
laugh at others
absolutely and so you wouldn't believe
some of the embarrassing and humiliating
things that have happened at work
and the good news when you hear these
stories there's always recovery
uh so so john has not heard these oh man
he's got some of my own problems so i'm
going to share these
and everybody's going to love we're
going to have some fun today so that's
coming up next segment but first let's
go to knoxville tennessee
where matt joins us matt you're on the
ramsay show how can we help
hey how you all doing well we're having
too much fun what's going on with you
so i'm in the process of having my first
kid with my wife
congratulations man well thank you thank
you
what do you all reckon would be a good
amount to save up for
having your first one million dollars
for diapers at least
yeah and that only covers the first two
years of their life
and then it's they get the pull-ups and
then it just never stops i can tell you
i did not know that diapers were
actually threaded with gold
and have diamond bits evidently because
they're a billion dollars
yeah all right let's talk matt
practically uh what's what is the out of
pocket if
any uh for uh the delivery labor and
delivery
for you i know i've i've talked to uh
different folks one
one thing you told me he's like yeah we
had our first kid
uh our bill afterwards was like 10 grand
the other one's like
well it was about two grand to me yeah
but here's the problem you're talking to
all the wrong
dudes those two dudes probably aren't
correct
uh and they've probably juiced that
number because they just think it's fun
to share of urban legend
and then third they don't they don't
have your health care plan so you need
to call your healthcare provider today
because absence of details john yes what
happens to the mind
it melts and hey what we're both going
to tell you matt as two dads here
yeah anything from this point forward
that you go into this situation when it
comes to the money not knowing
is a decision to be ignorant about it
don't do that to your wife don't do that
to yourself don't do that to this future
kid
there will be a cash option you can call
your insurance agent
or your insurance company and say what
is the cash option for the cost of this
baby assuming there's no
fill in the blank uh and then they
should also be able to tell your max out
of pocket the max of what it's going to
cost
figure all that stuff out have it on a
piece of paper so you know exactly what
you're walking into so there's your
number there matt that's your most
important number that you need to get a
hold of
so now you know the first part of this
question the second part of how much
should we save
is i do think it's really wise for you
guys to actually go
online or you can go to a grocery store
it's much easier to go online
and just look at i mean he's your wife
she could talk to her mom other
ladies in her life that have had babies
and you pick out okay i think i'm gonna
go with this branded diaper i'm gonna
get
i need wipes i need all the things get
the list of all the things
and then go online and just do a budget
just go okay
per this this this and this and again
you can talk to real ladies
uh who who have got kids in diapers and
you can
put together a really good idea of what
a monthly expense is going to look like
for diapers food wipes all that stuff
this is scary for you just because
you've not done your homework so go do
your homework as john said
and then we've got real numbers which
means we can develop a real plan
to save that money and i think you'll
find
there's something about new parents
because it's a
baby and it's a that's a human being
that you've got to like provide for and
raise john it's like and it's it's just
really not the nightmare that it
seems to be that would be my take no i i
it's the it's the
i told somebody yesterday it's the
hardest best thing you'll ever
experience right it's the hardest
best thing in the world oh man and i'll
tell matt whatever your budget is
it's going to be wrong so be graceful
with yourself too that's right yeah our
colleague rachel cruz says give yourself
90 days to just kind of figure this
thing out and then by then
you know kids are smoking and riding
bikes and the whole thing changes again
so
every it's just going to rotate be
grateful with yourself
do your planning as best you can up
front and then go from just horrified a
bunch of
expectant parents right they know they
know yeah well let's i will say this
uh i i'm a slightly slightly different
stage than you
uh 15 13 and 12. and let me just tell
you something it gets
way more expensive so let me just go
ahead and fire that one out there for
all of if you're worried about diapers
and baby food
let me tell you kelly daniels she's back
there shaking her head insurance in cars
oh i'm about ready to put a kid in a car
and honestly you're gonna have to
prescribe something for me
i don't know how i'm going to come into
work and do what i'm supposed
to do to help others when that kid is
out on the highway knowing there's
your child is driving a 2 000 pound
missile down i-65
yeah let me just put it out there for
the ramsey solutions tribe
if i disappear for about three months
later this year
you know i'm on medical leave for stress
and anxiety
because i'm like dude that's the next
level and i've not gotten there
no i i've got one child who
is already is critiquing my driving like
dad i think you should slow down
and then i've got another one in the
back going faster fast so yeah
i think every kid's gonna be different
yeah yikes but but on one hand i'm
excited you know not to get up
at 5 30 in the morning to take my kid to
football workouts
in the off season which is what i'm into
right now which i guess i should also
tell people since we're putting
qualifiers out there if i just pass out
right now during the show and head down
don't be alarmed john's got it we'll go
from there i just need to sleep it off
it's been awful early all right here's
what we got we're having fun
here's the phone number to jump in
triple eight eight two five five two two
five and coming up next
some hilarious work fails you won't
believe what people did
in the office and live to tell about it
don't move you're listening to the
ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners
we're intentional about choosing the
best advertisers
to recommend blinds.com is no exception
they offer high quality window
treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering
free shipping and a guaranteed perfect
fit
go to blinds.com and take advantage of
this week's special savings
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsay show i'm
ramsay personality and host of the ken
coleman show on the ramsey network ken
coleman joined by
my fellow ramsay personality dr john
delonie host of the dr john delony show
on
the ramsey solutions network that was a
lot of our names
yeah got it all out there i'm john this
is ken yeah well you know some people
are tuning in going hey i thought dave
was on today
uh he's uh he's taken up croquet he is
turning into a croquet champion as with
anything dave likes to go all in
and so unbeknownst to me there is uh
croquet lessons
he is in the yard right now right now
hammer in hand
really learning how to do it we just
folks
just kidding can you imagine james
people were like really dave
croquet i'm not seeing it well you're
right it sounds awfully loud
i don't know i don't know that that
would ever happen all right
so we're taking your calls triple eight
eight two five five two two five
triple eight eight two five five two two
five now we're gonna take your money
questions that's what the rams show
uh obviously has always been about but
as we as we expand on life topics
we're gonna take on relationship
questions marriage questions uh
kid parenting you know the whole nine
yards and then we talk about work hey
ken
i want to make more money i want to get
promoted i want to move up the ladder
because i'm working the baby steps
and i need a bigger shovel i'm your guy
dare i say i'm the big shovel guy even
though in real life you'd never see me
with a real shovel
i had a shovel at my property yesterday
but in here
you're the big shovel guy thank you and
then john and i like to team up on hey
i'm struggling at work i don't know how
to handle this difficult boss or
co-worker
toxicity that's where john is a
psychologist and trained counselor i
mean he jumps in as well so
we love those calls together but what we
thought we would do is have a little fun
on the ramsay show today with funny work
fails so james and kelly have not even
seen these and john hasn't either so
this is really fun
uh here we go this comes in from ben he
put this out on twitter he said
first day of the job in an educational
reference library
that was located in an old elementary
school hall
with floor-to-ceiling windows i couldn't
see my computer screen due to the sun so
i tried to pull
the heavy duty curtains closed
when i did the entire set of curtains
came down
including the guy on the stepladder who
had
just finished hanging them now
first day first day dude unbeknownst to
ben when he goes to close the curtains
there's a dude over there on a ladder
whose whole job is to make sure the
facilities are done properly like
everything's right
and he pulls the curtains down and looks
over it's not only embarrassing
we got our workers comp situation going
on right somebody's in the hospital
yes who's the new guy that just brought
the entire room of curtains down so
the moral of the story is don't touch
anything when you go to
to work on your first day right i think
that is just get through the day and i'm
going to expand that that's really good
don't touch anything even on your second
or your 22nd
or your 222nd day when it comes to those
kind of things that you're not gifted in
you're not quite sure about
go ahead and ask the facilities guy
about it and they'll start moving giant
look for the guy on the ladder maybe
yeah look for the guy on the ladder i
think ben
might have been really focused on
getting those curtains closed
so there you go next one rachel wrote
this one on facebook
she said i was working at a law firm oh
boy you're going to love
i can't wait for your comments go for it
i was working at a law firm and i was
incredibly bored the only way i could
make the time pass during the day
was by talking to myself pretending that
i was a guest on a late night show
one day kelly you're not even ready for
this my boss
came into my office hysterically
laughing because he had a security
camera directly
on me and had seen my entire fake
conversation lots of layers
on this one dude first of all she's
initially embarrassed because here she's
in
she's basically doing a jimmy kimmel
interview of herself alone
okay so the boss comes in laughing at
her lots of
lots of embarrassment but then how long
before she got creeped out that there
was a security camera pointed directly
at her and the boss was watching
you're watching it dude listen so
that that becomes uh uh number two
number one
don't touch anything at work just don't
number two
keep all the little voices in your head
to yourself number
three don't work for a leader who's got
a security camera trained on you
i'm not sure what do you think about
that james james has cameras
yeah james has cameras on us but that's
different that's cause youtube
so yeah there are eight cameras pointing
at us all right
there's james right now he loves being
on camera fantastic
okay so the real question here ken is
have you
ever done a
pretend interview for an interview show
yes uh when i was a kid because i always
kind of wanted to do what i'm doing and
broadcasting yeah
and took me a while to figure out it was
really the thing yeah
but yeah but not at work because the
real moral of the story here is the
reason i share these fails right
this one is ken coleman show ground zero
yeah don't like that
don't take a job and stay in a job where
you're so bored you go into imagination
land
it's just that's just not helping
anybody you're not even doing your job
all right here we go this is my personal
favorite folks
and by the way this is the one that i
would do
okay if i was gonna have a big work fail
on this list this is the one
my allergy medicate just from angela who
writes it on instagram
my allergy medication and my ambien
were both in the same size bottle no
both of them white tablets
on the first week of a new job first
thing in the morning i reached in my
purse at my desk opened the bottle and
swallow the pill
edit about a minute later i realized i
had swallowed the ambien not the allergy
medicine
i don't remember much except waking up
famous last words i don't remember much
except waking up in the company
meditation room four hours later the
secretary said i came running to her
desk and said over and over
i've overdosed and i need to go home
first of all you took an ambien you
didn't overdose yeah
imagine what that poor secretary was
thinking and she didn't call the
ambulance
is there a medical taking away space
here at ramsey solutions i don't i don't
i was gonna believe there is so i was i
knew you were gonna lock in on the
meditation room uh
this awesome secretary you talk about
teammate of the
of the year award directed her quietly
she took away my car keys and
led me to the meditation room and
that's a good woman right there can you
imagine four hours later
you wake up company meditation room
first week but that's a that's an extra
admin
admins run everything they are very
important people
and a great admin will save you from
your own embarrassment
and then when you come back they'll just
hand you your keys i mean seriously
that the moral of the story is be really
really kind
to the admin people always because they
save your bacon
and put a big just don't take ambien how
about that yeah oh don't take your
ambien
to work shouldn't even have been in the
purse no all right here we go now
that was the one that i think would most
likely happen to me i think this is the
one that might most likely happen to you
we'll see what you say okay
i tried to tell a code this is from
marla also on instagram
i tried to tell a co-worker hello one
morning when i was walking in
but it came out as howl as in like a dog
house so you know he's like how you
doing hello is what i think she was
trying to say james and she looks at the
guy they walk at each other and she goes
this is the best part he misheard me and
thought i had meowed at him
to which he politely me out back
it was a disaster from the beginning and
she doesn't say anything more so
so listen ken i want to analyze this one
about what you would do in this
situation well so
the other day i'm walking in see i knew
this could be i was walking in
and there was um it was brad and one
other person they were walking we have
walking trails here at rim solutions
people
are having walking meetings out here and
i could have gone with hey good morning
guys yeah i could have gone with
hey everybody and i went with
oh i made some weird like like whoa
what and then i stopped and i was like
guys i just
that was so weird and uncalled for
unnecessary that i
cause it's not like they were 100 yards
away no they're like facebook they were
10 yards for me and suddenly i
transported myself to some
rock wyoming yeah like uh uh
cowboy event i don't know what i was
doing you know like yeah
it was frustrating if that happens to me
kelly i gotta tell you i need to stop
and address it right then and there's
this gal kept going both of these people
walk away
see um just me the guy thinks that she
meowed at him so he goes
okay i'm in i'll meow back at you so now
they both think and now we have a
general issue we've got couples meowing
at each other you can't have that at the
workplace
right that's why i gotta go hey i gotta
tell you i just tried to do this
it came out this you me out back i'm not
sure what that was
can we just start all over said guys i
just made this weird and i'm sorry i
didn't mean for it to be weird i was
just
trying to be here's the good news even
if you've had a workplace fail
you can you can recover or you can get
fired go work somewhere else
either way we'll help you get a
different job
all right your calls phone lines are
filling up they're coming up next
i'm ken coleman he's dr john daloni and
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
so
[Music]
ramsay show continues from our ramsay
solutions studios in nashville
the phone number to jump in on the phone
is triple eight eight two
five five two two five that's triple
eight eight two five five two two five
i'm ken coleman
joined by my colleague dr john deloney
and we are with you this hour
taking your calls about life money work
relationships you want to move up you
want to have a healthy relationship with
your spouse your kids
uh we're going to dive in on all of that
but first
blinds.com's 100 satisfaction guarantee
means even if you mismeasure or pick the
wrong color which i would do both john
correct they'll remake your blinds for
free or if you just start a new job and
you pull the string and the whole thing
comes down on top of you and you've got
to get some more
yeah that's it too you get free samples
free shipping with the new promos they
run every month you'll save even more
use the promo code ramsey
to get the best deal rules and
restrictions apply
today's question comes from david and
george i'm 32 years old and i'm on baby
step
7. whoa way to go david i've been
disciplined and intense with money since
i was 18 years old i am feeling
very all caps discouraged
knowing that i'm fighting this whole
thing single-handedly how can i be
intentional about meeting someone to
marry
oh david wants to get hitched that's a
loaded question that we could literally
take
a full show to answer yeah i would love
to talk to david here
sometimes people get so intense
about goals and objectives
they then want to use that same energy
and model for human connection
and any time a person yeah becomes a
goal
or a strategy or an objective you've
devalued that relationship and that's
not somebody who has any business
marrying you
and you shouldn't marry them yeah right
so
for somebody who is hyper goal driven
hyper outcome focused human
relationships are going to be
challenging
right um what do you think ken
well the question is how can i be
intentional about meeting someone
to marry put yourself in situations
where you're going to meet people so i
wrote this book called the proximity
principle that had nothing to do with
marriage but it applies here as well the
proximity principle
came from the show when i just started
giving people advice on how to get where
they want to go
and it simply says this in order to do
what you want to do you got to be around
people that are doing that
in places where it is happening so if
you want to get intentional about
meeting people to marry
you start going what's the type of woman
i want to marry
you know don't turn it into a giant
checklist like john saying
however you can say hey i want to meet
this type of woman who maybe has these
values and guess what once we have a
general idea of what we're looking for
in a life mate
then we know where those people are see
before that i want him to i love the
idea of proximity
i want him just to start hanging out
with people well i think he probably is
you think so yeah it's hard to read into
this question here's my point
you want to meet women then where are
go be around women type of women yeah
it's like uh here's the here's the one
idea
just be a normal human being and hang
out with other people and groups to i
think that's what you're saying
and then if you see a woman that is
attractive to you uh you be a gentleman
and you ask them out and if she says no
don't go back to your cave and suck your
thumb
do it again and eventually someone will
say yes
and then be a gentleman and keep doing
it until finally john
tada the light bulb goes off let's not
overthink this how do i be intentional
to meet somebody be intentional meet
women don't be a creeper and uh
be clear on what you think you want your
wife
to uh be like sound like act like
whatever you just have to
be a person uh that other people want to
be in partnership with
be a person who's yeah shows up and is
safe
and is kind and treats people with
dignity yeah and is respectful of be
be a person that someone wants to
connect with yeah and david you know
what i i'm feeling this was a little
bonus advice
what's the bonus i'm reading into this
we got to be fair folks we have limited
information here it's not a caller i
think david needs to be careful on date
number one
not to like do a full expose on these
gals finances
he's intense yeah don't talk about your
money man yeah chill out on the money
right now
cause you're you're in baby step seven
you're in good shape you can do this but
does it make sense what i'm saying
eventually
if he meets somebody and asks him out
and the goal of this is not
to get to know somebody to hang out and
to have some laughs
right to learn about somebody the goal
is to begin
running the algorithm of this person
yeah material not a good idea no
no you're gonna scare girls scare them
you're gonna melt people
yeah and you're very that you put here
in all caps is gonna get bigger and
bigger and bigger your discouragement is
going to get more frustrating
meet people for the sake of meeting
people be with people for the sake of
being
people and from that you'll develop
relationships with folks that will turn
into something bigger and better than
that
yeah and you know what go read some
books on some older classic books on
what it means to be a gentleman if i was
going to give advice to any young dude
these days i'd go you know what
i don't care what the world's telling
you i don't care what culture has become
i'm telling you be a gentleman what does
that mean
to me yeah well as relates to relating
to women it's
first and foremost you may be attracted
to them but you still must respect them
treat them open their car door listen to
them
you know value them yeah don't just be
attracted to them they're not an
object they are a beautiful part of this
world and so being a gentleman
is kind respectful thoughtful
uh not selfish with women in every
aspect i'll just leave it at that i
think it's pretty obvious yeah but i
i think it's obvious i don't know that a
lot of young 20-somethings
think about what it means to be a
gentleman and how you treat
women i love it a lot of the garbage
that's going on in the world
if even if you're unhealthy but if you
go you know what i got to be a gentleman
yeah i got to be a gentleman like dads
if we were teaching our boys to be
gentlemen
a lot of stuff going on between the
sexes would would not be as gross
if we were just treat each other with
dignity right this is the standard yeah
i'm gonna be a gentleman it starts um
with young people watching their parents
treat each other right
that's right and talk to each other with
dignity and treat each other with
respect and
not throwing temper tantrums yeah adults
throw temper tantrums and
treating each other with yeah with
utmost dignity and respect
and kids learn by watching man yeah yeah
but we have long since gotten over the
art form of just teaching manners and
just
how do you just treat people so i know
i'm old school in it right now but there
it is old school too
all right here we go triple eight eight
two five five two two five
let's go to green bay wisconsin where
bridgette is on the line bridget you're
on the ramsey show
hey ken and dr d it's nice to speak with
you today
well it's our thrill to talk to you
what's up
well i am calling i am a newly divorced
mom of
five kids all 10 and under oh including
one with
including one with special needs wow
bridgette
there's a lot yes um i've been out of
the workforce for about 11 years now
raising my kids
i'm in a stable financial position crazy
god because my husband is a physician
and so he is able to support me to be
able to stay home a little bit longer
with the kids but
i know that that's just a short-term
solution to
a long-term problem so i'm really
looking to be proactive at this point
about
figuring out what the next step looks
for me um
through this very painful divorce
process my confidence has really been
shaken
i do have sole custody of my kids he has
them
one weekend a month and so
you know with five there's before school
costs there's after-school costs there's
um you know my youngest is not even two
yet so there's going to be day care
costs and
um so i'm really just trying to figure
out you know how do i
a figure out what my passion is at this
point or what my
my sweet spot is i have some ideas but
practically how do i get there when
i need to make a certain income for it
to even make sense for me to go back to
work because of the child care
costs and or the time restrictions i
have
being a single parent of so many little
people yeah okay so here's what we're
going to do bridgette
we're about a minute away from going to
commercial break but we're going to hold
you over but i want john
just to give you a minute pep talk on
the confidence fact because this is
this is really key yeah to get this part
and then i'm going to come back from the
break and i'll help you on the other
john
coach you're up um how long ago was this
divorce
i we finalized june of 2020 um
i knew things were going south about
four months after our youngest was born
and i was
asked for a divorce in november of 19.
so
this is something that has been brewing
and
rattling around for several years right
um yes and no i mean i was i felt very
blindsided
yeah the blind side that hurts that
hurts stay tuned we're going to talk
about all this when we write when we
come back
don't move the ramsey show
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thanks for joining us here on the ramsay
show i'm ken coleman joined by my
colleague dr john deloney we're ramsey
personalities we also host our own shows
of course on
the ramsey solutions network and we are
taking you through this hour of the
ramsay show
triple eight eight two five five two two
five triple eight eight two five five
two two five let's talk life
what do you got uh we're here for you
now before we went to break we'd just
taken bridget
uh who is in green bay wisconsin and
she's a single mom
of five just recently divorced
confidence is low
understandably and now she's looking to
re-enter the workforce been out of work
for 11 years
all right and so john you're going to
coach her up a little bit on that
confidence thing and then she wants to
walk through
she thinks she knows a little bit about
what her sweet spot is
but how do we translate that into
options
and then opportunities and so we go back
to bridgette now bridget
uh i'm gonna let john pick it back up
here and talk to you about that
confidence
so bridgette you have been out for 11
years
you were blindsided by this um divorce
and it's been about a year
or about half a year since it's been
finalized about right
that's right and so when you are
picturing i know you've
you're a mom of five which means you can
just pretty much do anything
and you're the mother of a special needs
kid which means you're a bulldog too you
can get it done
and there's a math problem here right
you can look at the math here's what i'm
gonna have to do
you said all the right things it's a
short-term solution long-term problem
you know all that stuff
but when it's the kids are all five of
those kids are in bed
and everybody that the house gets quiet
and you are starting to think about what
tomorrow's gonna look like
talk to me about what you feel
i mean really i think my day-to-day
confidence i'm very confident myself as
a mother
my ability to raise my kids i think
really a lot of the confidence and
you've said this before because i do
listen to your show a lot too
is um you know i i don't you know i do
don't or i do have trouble um trusting
myself
because there was an infidelity that i
didn't see coming at all
the the person i married was not the
person i expected him to be
why didn't i see all of this stuff um
and
then you know i have you know using
ken's materials i have had a few
um interviews even but it always comes
down to you know we just want somebody
with more recent experience
or because i'm from the marketing field
i i was
working 11 years ago before social media
really was a big thing
um and so you know i think there's also
the confidence and the work
aspect because of the feedback that i've
been getting when i
when i do get interviews right so you
nailed it on the head that
the trust here that you've got to regain
you're gonna have to regain trust in
humanity and
all that the trust you've got to regain
is in yourself and what i want you to do
on a daily basis is look at all of the
little things you are able to accomplish
and do these are little steps these are
little
little things that you're gonna say i am
literally
wrangling five human beings i am able to
navigate this messy school stitch
under 10 for crying out loud i've got
two and i
you're i don't even know how you're
doing what you're doing it's about
slowly regaining trust in yourself and
you're gonna have to do it intentionally
meaning
you can't let a day go by that you don't
reflect on the day at the things you
were able to accomplish
that you don't go through a day that you
don't reflect on the people you touched
and impacted in positive ways
and over time you're going to slowly see
and slowly see and then
big time and i'll pass it off to ken
you've got to have friends in your life
that will speak truth to you
you can't see everything on your own so
you're going to have to have people that
are reporting back to you experiencing
you and feeling you
and able to say hey you missed this one
or
you didn't see how good of a job you did
with this situation all right bridgette
here we go
and i'm blessed with a great support
system
that's huge okay so bridgette your real
question is it
direction the type of work that you want
to do because you mentioned the sweet
spot for those people that are
new to my content that's where you use
your talent what you do best
to perform your passion this is work
that you really love think of a task a
role a function
and then finally you use that talent to
do
passion to accomplish mission that's
results that matter deeply to you
what are you sure of and what are you
not sure of
well you know when i really sit down and
look at it
definitely my passion is for people
helping people and passionate about
especially helping mothers
and i love beauty i love you know seeing
a
final product and seeing you know like
i've um i bought a home and i've been
slowly redoing the whole thing myself
and i love the before and afters and
those types of things those are my
passions
um as far as what my my my strengths are
i'm really i mean i'm really good at
building relationships with people i'm
really good at being approachable easy
to talk to
um i mean i've worked from anything from
you know a group on a farm to million
dollar
corporation owners in my former role and
so i'm really good at connecting with
people from all walks of life
uh i'm a phenomenal writer i know that
most of the jobs that i was interviewed
for it was
for writing type positions um because
that's also
a strength teaching bridgette is this
recent
you were interviewing for writing
positions recently
yes okay and what you're hearing is is
we want someone with a little bit more
experience
not more experience just recent
experience because i've
i've done a number of volunteer work in
the last 11 years but because
you know and i've done a touch of
freelancing here and there but
you're really looking for somebody who
is more current and especially with the
digital stuff because i've been out for
11 years yeah all right let me let me
let me have some fun with you
on this particular issue because i heard
some different things in there
you gave us some other evidence and you
didn't mention in your talents
that you're creative and you are
creative in your writing
but i also think you have a creative eye
am i right about that you got a creative
eye with decorating or restoring things
of that nature is that true or false
that's true and i mean i get good
graphic design as well my previous i'm
really good with
visuals colors yeah you didn't mention
that you didn't mention it specifically
but i heard it so here's
here's the fun that i'm talking about
okay i want you to answer this question
what would you do tomorrow if i just
waved the old pencil in my hand and poof
i gave you a job
that you knew you could not fail at you
knew
you were going to be successful but you
didn't have to
re just decide on that for the rest of
your professional career what would you
try
um i don't know if there's a job title
for it but i think what i would love to
do
is i call it being a mentor mom and just
helping moms to be better moms
so i love teaching i love training
especially adults um
and i would love just to help with home
management and home organization
and you know schedules because obviously
juggling five kids i i have unique
experiences in that and
um i've you know helped with the mops
organization and stuff like that
um so let me give you go ahead keep
going
i was going to say you know kind of it
would just be the whole gamut of you
know making a house a home really
okay something i love and then
counseling is also something i've
thought about but
going back to school with five kids and
here's the deal that counseling thing is
your attempt to give yourself some
safe uh well this is a good job
you just answer the question that's what
you would go for
and so we have to work towards that now
here's the challenge you're financially
stable right now
but there's a time period by which you
know i'm going to have to generate money
i want to make sure and we're going to
before we let you go we'll make sure
that kelly gets you
a membership to ramsey plus i want to
make sure that you're using our budget
tools and everything to begin to plan to
say
when will i have to make x amount of
dollars and i actually want you to get a
day job
i want you to actually just get
something that where again
where you and i'm going to give you a
copy of my book the proximity principle
because you just got to reconnect with
everybody you know
here you've been out of the workforce
for 11 years but you haven't been out of
life for 11 years
and we've got to stop applying for
things where people don't know bridget
they're just like oh this is bridget we
interview and we go well she hasn't
written in 11 years we're not going to
take her no
i want you in interviews that you've
gotten because friends and family have
said
hey i know somebody over there they're
going to interview you based on
our relationship credibility and they're
not going to dismiss you they're going
to hear how
talented you are but i want you to use
the proximity principle i'm going to
give you the book i want you to read it
and do it exactly the way i write it
it'll help you step by step to get
connected so you get jobs
so let's get yourself a day job that's
paying
you what you need to make to keep
stability
going that you addressed at the
beginning of our phone call that's step
one that's what you do now then i want
you to launch on the side and i know you
got five kiddos
but i want you to start creating some
content maybe it's on instagram maybe
it's on facebook
maybe it's both maybe it's volunteering
at the local mops thing and showing up
and giving a free talk
and begin to coach women and give
yourself away to women
to help them be better moms i think it's
a side hustle that eventually becomes
john
her full-time gig that saturday month
when the kids are with dad
that's you're all in you're going to
have people go to your house you're
going to do seminars yes
create content show your work so hang on
the line we're going to get
ramsey plus and get you a copy of the
proximity principle but bridget i want
you to hear this
you got this you got it you can do this
this is the ramsey
[Music]
this is james childs producer of the
ramsay show did you know the ramsay show
is one of the most popular podcasts in
the world
subscribe or follow today wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio this is the ramsey
show
this is where america is hanging out to
have a conversation big conversations
important stuff
about your life your money your career
your relationships
mental and emotional health welcome one
and all i'm ken coleman
i'm host of the ken coleman show part of
the ramsey network and i'm joined by my
colleague dr john delaney who hosts the
dr john delony
on the ramsey solutions network and we
are here together for
you this hour triple eight eight two
five five
two two five triple eight eight two five
five two two five doc you ready to hit
the phones
do it all right we started off the
shower with seth
in fort smith arkansas seth how can we
help
hey guys how are y'all doing today oh
we're having a blast what's going on
okay i've got a question for you guys um
i'm i'm 35 years old um
financially fairly stable um my question
is
how to balance the side jobs the side
gigs the
extracurricular work if you will and
family i've got two kids
um i've got a little boy that will be
four
in july and one that will be one uh in a
month
um what's the what's the goal seth
what's the goal of this side work
to be debt-free i am so sick and tired
my wife and i both and we're both on the
same page i'm tired of making monthly
payments
on it how close are emotional decisions
how close are you dangerously close
um the only debt that we have besides
the mortgage
is we owe about 5 800 on a car um
you're real close i mean what's your
payoff right
there what's your payoff date on the car
if everything stays the same
if we just if we just make the payments
as scheduled
um about uh 13 14 months
no no no i thought you were i thought
you were working really hard i'm saying
with your goal how long before you
expect to pay this off working all these
side jobs if everything goes according
to plan
three four or five months something like
that
um okay hold on a second
hold on keep on playing this out and
then how many more months to have that
three to six month emergency fund funded
probably another well with that extra
with the extra kick with the the car
payment being gone probably
three or four months okay so here's the
deal
i know a lot of men myself included who
did a lot of extra jobs
we told ourselves it was because of the
money but it really was because we were
insecure
we were awkward around our families or
our friends
and i was we are i was chasing
external validation so when someone
asked me to do something absolutely i'm
in
all right you need this thing i can do
that i can help with that and it was
constant movement movement movement
movement
and as you're feeling right now my my
family's the one that suffered for it
the other side of that is families often
sell themselves short you guys can do
anything for
one two three four years when you are
grinding out
sprinting gazelletons towards a goal
and that's where you're at and it's
uncomfortable and you're watching these
precious moments of your kids
slip through your fingers some of that
is paying the piper for
as you said living a life that that you
couldn't afford
and you got to get caught up the other
side of that is brother you are real
real close
what do you what do you uh how would you
define out of balance that's the crux of
your question how do i
how do i have balance and i want to know
where you feel the stress or the pain
of being out of balance describe that
briefly
the fact that and my wife feels like
in a sense that she's a single parent
you know because i work a lot um
you know i'm out of town so i'm not a
whole lot but some
um but you know i'm going from the house
before eight every morning and lots of
times it's
8 39 9 30 10 o'clock at night before i
roll back up
and you know i saw my kids for
15 minutes in the morning and that's the
extent of my interaction with my
children
got it yeah all right so uh
this is this is what i think you should
do i think you've got to sit down
by yourself and go can i keep this up
and do i think my wife can handle this
for i think you said three or four more
months just to pay off the car
um that's a short-term sacrifice that i
think is gonna pay off
big time but i think if you're willing
to do it
if your heart can handle it and you
think your wife can i would i would
determine that john first then i'd sit
down with the wife and go hey i'm
hearing you
and you know why i'm doing this but i'm
just gonna remind you i'm doing this for
us um are you okay if i if we just bite
the stick and we bear down
uh for three four more months and at
that point i'll knock one of the jobs
off or you guys sit down and talk about
it and then you can slow down a little
bit
if you feel like your hearts can't keep
this up and and then it just takes a
little bit longer to get that emergency
fund going
uh the other side of that is you know
reassess
you know some other ways that you might
be able to juice that emergency fund by
selling even more stuff you know you
guys know your budget you know your
situation but i
i think i would stay on the gazelle
intensity the way you're working right
now
until you get the car paid off take a
deep breath
maybe even find a better job could you
do
one job that pays what you're doing in
two extra jobs
start to just really get innovative and
creative um because i think we can
always do that when there's a will
there's a way is it old phrase and i
think that's really true
and seth there is something magic about
sitting down
with a calendar and your wife and saying
with a big red pen
saying this is when this ends and you
have to commit
in and be a person of integrity and
keep your word and say the day that we
cross this threshold i'm quitting this
job
and you get your husband back and not
only do you get your husband back
physically your presence there but i'm
going to be invested because i'm not
going to be running scared anymore
i'm going to be able to slow down and i
love what ken said that's when you start
able to thinking about man what's
another career look like we can make
some more money what does what do we
want to do
who do we want to be now that we're done
sprinting to get away from this this
lion
yeah but i i love ken's advice man sit
down with your wife with a calendar and
say
this is the end of this you just told us
three four five months that's a big gap
brother and then another three four or
five months to get your emergency fund
if you can tell me from right now six
months from today you are debt-free and
you got a
an emergency fund and you can sit down
your wife and circle that big on the
calendar
and say after this is when we're going
on a trip we're going camp we're doing
something
man everybody can get through that
together but you just got to be super
super clear
seth real quick uh are you working seven
days a week five days a week six what
does it look like
it kind of depends so i i'm a welder and
i have a
quote day job um that is basically a
monday through friday gig
some weekends but not and then i also
have my own equipment and i do some
freelance stuff some you know
yeah somebody needs something well they
call me and i will fix it or you know
whatever
so roughly you gotta you got you got at
least a saturday a couple times a month
where you're not working or you're
working every saturday uh
no i i make it a point at this at this
time
good to to have some time to where
it's good us it's just our core family
and
you know get off facebook and so here's
what i want you to hear from me seth
everything john and i said still holds
but you know what you need to do
maybe you need to do laundry all day on
a saturday exactly right and actually
let her
not parent at all and yes it goes a long
way
yes you're tired do laundry anyway you
can handle it it's six more months you
got this
yep give her some relief not just be
home
all right good stuff thanks for the call
good good good stuff all right don't
move
more of your calls about your life your
money your career your relationships
you're listening to the ramsey show
you know health care has gotten to be
ridiculous
it puts people um you know on the brink
and so it would have put us on the brink
had we not had
chm chm saved our life same brought to
my financial lives
christian healthcare ministries or chm
is not health insurance
but it is a budget-friendly option and
the original health cost sharing
ministry for christians
get started today and check us out at
chministries.org
backslash budget
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the ramsay show continues from our
ramsey solutions studios in nashville
thrilled to have you with us triple
eight eight two five
five two two five is the toll-free
number
it is your show america triple eight
eight two five five two two five i'm ken
coleman joined by my colleague dr john
delony
and we're gonna go to phoenix arizona
next where cameron is on the line
cameron how can we help hey ken how's it
going i'm uh i'm stoked that you guys
are filling in for the show today i just
kind of i've wanted to tell you for a
long time you are the man i appreciate
you
and all the work that you do well that's
very nice it's very nice i will send you
a check after the show today
that sounds good yeah how can we help um
and and and john i also wanted to really
quickly i wanted to tell you
you know my wife and i bought your book
a couple months back you helped us
through a really hard time so i
appreciate the work that you guys do
thanks brother appreciate it man very
kind so what's up no problem so
i've got a question so i um right now
i've got a full-time job and i've got a
i'm trying to live the dream as a uh
turning my side gig into my full-time
job
um and i'm looking to expand a little
bit but the more that i
grow i really i'm just realizing more
and more that i am i am just one person
and i can work as much as i can work
especially having a full-time job
and wife and a child at home and so i'm
looking into
um kind of expanding i i don't
necessarily know the difference between
1099
and having an employee surface level i
know that 1099
seems a little bit better for me but i
wanted to get your guys's opinion on the
difference
what's the work you do and what would
the work be
for a person that you would hire
so i i i do wedding films
so people hire me to film their wedding
and then i give them a video
to basically as a memory um so
the work that i would hire out would be
if i am
booked a certain day or if i'm working a
certain day i would
i would basically contract out
um that that wedding to somebody else
and then i would take over any editing
portion but i didn't know if that was
the best way to go about it yeah i think
it absolutely is i think
if for a small business like yours where
you are the business even as you begin
to hire maybe some other camera
folks um you're still the guy you're the
business because you're the
relationships and they're kind of
getting you
from word of mouth is probably most
likely how you get your business so
at this stage of the company i like the
10.99 it's just a contract
you pay them and you issue them a 1099
your bookkeeper does that it's a lot
cleaner a lot easier as opposed to you
making them a full-time employee
there's a lot more work there and
expense for you as well you're just not
there yet this is such a
labor driven business you know
i i just i love you stay in 1099 as long
as you can would be my advice
and usually the rule of thumb on the
1099 is if they're bringing their own
tools
and they're bringing their own camera
their own stuff and they're handing you
over that raw
product then you can feel good about
that kind it's when they're coming to
pick them up
you're up your equipment your stuff
they're showing up with you and they
was it all walks like a duck and talks
like a duck if they're an employee of
yours and they're going to work every
day and you'll have a big business going
then the right thing to do is to make
them an employee okay awesome and then i
do have a follow-up question if you'll
allow it um
i i guess i'm just wondering um my my
wife
is she grew up in a household where you
go
to a job and it's secure and that brings
some sort of peace to her so
the idea of me jumping from my um
full-time job into this um side gig
that seems to be a forever side gig in
her mind
i guess once the income the goal for us
is to match my
my side gig income to my full-time
income
and then just kind of take a smooth step
but i'm just wondering
is this step going to be scary like no
matter what or should it feel
completely natural i guess i'm just it
should feel hard for us it's scary
yeah i get it first of all to be scared
of it is to kind of go
oh my gosh moving from where someone
else is paying me to i got to pay myself
that's scary in and of itself but this
is a math
problem and once we solve the math
problem
then the emotions can come along with it
so i don't think it should be scary but
here's what would need to be true in my
opinion
because i'm thinking of stacey in the
same situation and what would i need to
do to make stacey not feel scared and
myself not be scared so it's two things
one i've got to be generating the income
in the side hustle
to be able to pay myself what i'm making
and i would have no debt right and then
i'd go a step further just walk the baby
steps out okay so baby step two
is paying off the debt baby step three
of course is your three to six months
emergency fund i'd go above and beyond
that i'd have your emergency fund
for life but then before i left the day
job this would be what i would do
before i left the day job i would have
almost an emergency fund in the business
account
and that would be at least six months of
what you pay yourself
already sitting in the account that
would be a minimum for me and then you
sit down with your wife and you go hey
look we we have no debt
we've got our personal emergency fund in
place we're walking this thing out and
then in the business the wedding
photography or videography business i've
got six months
of my salary already in the bank and
i've got work lined up
and so i think when you get to that
point i'd feel pretty darn good about
going for it
and understand this cameron dave tells a
great story about it
it was his grandma uh oh you sir i think
that's who it was
that he was making millions when she
would mention to him hey when are you
gonna just get a real job right because
there are people who
a real job is a place that you go and
you get a paycheck and a w-2
that's just in some people's hearts and
minds you're not going to change that
with everybody
but ken touched on it great it's about
security for your wife
it's about safety it's about do you know
what you're actually doing and you're a
dreamer you're a go-getter
but you also got to do the hard math
problems because they don't lie yeah
and once she knows that we are going to
be okay
then you watch the fear dissipate and
she'll get excited so it's just a little
extra work and here's another thing too
john it's about patience
everybody who's got a dream certainly
the entrepreneur they want to get to it
as fast as possible
and i get it but the way to succeed as
an entrepreneur is to
wait wait wait and i think my advice for
all young entrepreneurs and my advice
for you
is what mel gibson's character william
wallace says in braveheart with those
oh the british army is thunder hold
hold and it gets more intense as they
get closer and that's the thing
as you get closer and closer to being
able to step full time
just keep to the plan and then that
extra hold hold
like when we get there then okay boom
pick up the sticks because six
before you're planning to jump your boss
is gonna mouth off and yeah
get mad that co-worker is gonna
hold hold hold hold it's one of my
favorite scenes in the movie and it
turns out it's great advice for
entrepreneurs
as well all right let's go to brad in
spokane washington brad you're on the
ramsay show guys thanks for taking my
call
so i'm kind of in a situation um i have
an opportunity to
take a job uh that is about a
twenty thousand dollar pay cut
from where i'm currently at but it
offers more stability
staying around town um versus the
current position
where you know i would say that there's
still stable
but um you know 15 years from now
you know i don't know where i will
technically be uh where it'll be same
place or
on the road traveling for work
but it is 20 000 more a year
roughly so i'm trying to make a decision
on this and i'm
just asking for some help sure so could
you absorb if you were to take it today
could you absorb financially in your
budget could you absorb the 20 000
pay cut and not be super super tight
um we could
uh what would need to be true to what
would need to be true
to be able to to take it and not be
super tight
we'd have to push back our date on house
being our
debt free with our house okay but but
but you have no debt except your home is
that what you're telling me
yeah and if i took this job i would have
to push that date back
uh right now we're on track to be paid
off within within the
next year um sometimes okay that's good
so we're just trying to assess this okay
so the next question i have is
if you take this job and it's 20 000 pay
cut
does it offer you a ladder hold on
because a lot of people ask this
question we got to do a commercial break
we're going to come back to you brad
because
there's a lot more here and john and
i'll dive into that don't move
you're listening to the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back to the ramsay show i'm ken
coleman joined by my colleague the
shower dr john deloney and before we
went to break
we had just piped brad in from spokane
washington and uh so his question uh
you know how do i know how do i know
when to switch and
uh you know you've got a situation where
he's got a side hustle
and uh so we're gonna bring him back in
so
so brad are you there yep
all right so ask your question for us
and we're gonna dive in here so we kind
of gave some context we kind of set you
up so
so hit us with your question
how do i decide if i'm making the right
decision to move
um to a different company
based on the factors with you know less
pay
but more stability versus more pay
that's right all right so and then and
so where we are
is is you said to me that you could but
i'm repeating this because i think
i was unclear and how i asked you i said
could you take the 20 000 hit and
not be super super tight
meaning if you're really really tight i
don't like the idea of taking this
particular job i'd rather you look for
something else
and and you said we can do it and not be
super super tight is that true
yeah okay so now my next question is
does this job even though it's a twenty
thousand dollar pay cut
does it provide a ladder for you is it
something that maybe in six months or a
year you're actually making that money
back
and you see long term that i could keep
climbing
uh it does it would take you know
possibly six years and then i would have
to go back to school
as well that's too long to get some
that's too long i think you're a guy
who's in really really good
financial shape and you know what you're
doing and and i think that to take a 20
000
hit uh to then see six years before you
can recoup that
i think you need to be more patient and
look for a better
opportunity to switch why do you want
out of your current job man
you know i it was an opportunity that
came up that i was just kind of
recommended to throw my
my resume in you know i really didn't
look for a job
i'm really happy with where i'm at um
does it feel good that somebody called
you out and recognized you
yeah sure it does yeah it definitely did
well here's the deal
brad i'm not hearing anything and again
tell us if we're missing something
but you really enjoy your job you're not
unhappy so to take a 20 000
hit i see no logical reason why you
would do that
am i missing something
no you know my wife uh and i have been
talking about it and she pretty much has
said the same thing but i'm uh
an avid dave ramsey listener and i
figured i would uh
give you guys a call you know i'm 99
sure i'm i'm not going to
i'll take it but that one percent of me
is just
i don't know if i'm making the right
decision you are making the right
decision
here's the thing man when you're dating
somebody and that
two years three years four years goes by
and you walk into that restaurant
and that person across the room just
gives you the eyebrow
it feels good it does that doesn't mean
you throw away everything you've got
it doesn't mean you go running towards
that it's going to be
20 000 it's going to be less than right
it feels good to be wanted it feels good
hey put your hat in the ring it feels
good
but man sounds like what you've got is
golden and you're a year away from
paying your house off you're you're
right there
um go with your gut on this man and more
importantly
go with what your wife sees and feels in
you right yeah she knows
i would actually don't tell her that you
called us tell her that she was right
the whole time
because i think that she's absolutely
right you need to listen there's no
reason i'm
all for stepping backwards if it's the
only way or the best way to move
upwards and in this case that is not
present at all so
be patient you're good to go triple
eight eight two five
five two two five is the number to jump
in let's go
to justin in san antonio texas justin
how can we help
hi gentlemen um well basically i'm in
graduate school
and got married last july
and i was wondering how we could follow
the baby steps
while we're going through while i'm
still in school what are you studying
man
i'm working on my phd in math
well that's a john doloni question if
i've ever heard one right there buddy
boy you've been
through this do you know any of my
statistics professor you know this is
not a question for me man
phd in math way to go brother so um
walk is your wife working yes we both
work full-time
in addition to me being a full-time
student so
what's the what is the challenge you are
experiencing with just following the
baby steps
normally well we're on baby step number
two okay
and i have 58 000 in federal student
loans
okay so that and we want to get that
paid off
excellent so you're going to follow your
baby steps just like you normally would
you're both
working full time grad school in many
ways for
who's working full-time getting phd in
math as you go think of it
this may demean it a bit but this is a
hobby at this point this is something
you're doing on the side it's a side gig
and so the critical important thing here
is you're not going into any more debt
for this degree are you guys cash flow
on this phd
yes um yeah we've been doing that now
for
well since uh we got married excellent
so in cash
if that if that's taken care of with
cash
then all you're going to do is follow
the baby steps as though you're
following the baby steps
right so you're going to continue to pay
off your debts smallest to largest take
your 58 000 in student loans
um hopefully you haven't consolidated
them and they're going to be in these
in these bite-sized chunks and you're
going to line them up and you're just
going to knock them out one after the
other
what other debt do you guys have besides
that 58 000
that's it yeah we both have um we paid
cash for our cars and all that
excellent dude so you're way ahead of
the game don't overthink this phd in
mathematics
yeah simple as can be yeah i'm just
curious what were you leaning towards
have you been tempted to stop the baby
steps and
put more i mean what you called because
you're like should i keep doing it or
how do i do this and
you're you're doing it the same way you
do it what's behind that question
well because um in in our budget we have
cost of classes you know built in so
that i'm
paying for it throughout the year you
know putting it in the savings
but you know that's taking away from
what i really wanted to
put towards that 58 000 just you know
with the gazelle intensity you know
well what what could you pause could you
pause the phd
how far along are you um
well i'm actually transitioning from
masters to phd now
okay are you are you a professor do you
have four years
do you have to have this doctorate right
now are you a professor
i'm not a professor i'm a high school
teacher okay so what's your end game
with this doctorate in math
i want to teach at the university okay
so here's
this is this is an existential
conversation for you guys
but if you're able to pause for 24
months
teach at a local community college there
there's several in san antonio you can
do that with a master's degree
and they're always short math teachers
at local community colleges get some
teaching experience in addition to your
high school experience
get that debt paid off asap and then
circle back yeah i i knew there was
something behind that
and i'm going to tell you something
justin i do not go forward on phd right
now you know why the phd's still going
to be there
and you're feeling in your gut which is
all coming from your head and heart
being on the same page and your head and
hearts going
we really should probably kind of kind
of put everything we've got
all of our guns pointed at the 58 000.
john's absolutely right and i'm going to
tell you even more forcefully
that phd is going to be there your dream
is going to be there and you're actually
going to get there
faster when you actually can pay off
that debt this is such a game changer
i'd go hard at the 58 and hold on the
phd
and for what it's worth um i've got
gaps in my education too for various
reasons yeah nobody cares it's not going
to end yet okay
if you were a professor and got hired
with a master's degree
and in order to keep your position you
had two more years left to finish that
doctorate then i'd tell you hit the gas
on that doctor and finish it
that's just not your case really go back
it's a hobby
it's an idea it's a dream it's something
we're going to do later man
just let all of the air out of your home
all that tense attention out of your
home by getting your debt paid off now
then circle back and go and i like the
idea there's a lot of folks who teach
high school that think teaching college
is going to be different it's going to
be easier it's going to be better i can
do research
i love the idea of you adjuncting at a
local community college or one or two or
three
in the san antonio area i love getting a
taste for college teaching
it's often not nearly as easy as people
think it is
amen and amen that's great advice right
there
and it by the way that's going to move
you along professionally as well
there's no shame in teaching on the
community college level
great exhaust incredible advice andy's
going to get the juice from that
and he's paying off debt or he's going
to save himself four years and 100 grand
realizing he might realize i don't teach
at college either that's right i love
that good stuff all right folks
don't move we're gonna talk about the
value of teachers you're gonna hear from
one next this is the ramsay
[Music]
so
[Music]
welcome back america you are listening
to the ramsey show
i think i just said america
unintentionally i think i just pulled a
texas
america out for you there john delaney
you you you miraculous i did you did
i didn't mean to folks but i just said
it a little
quick and i just went whoa what was that
we accept your apology go ahead very
good america
welcome back to the ramsay show i'm ken
coleman joined by
texas born and bred dr john deloney and
we are thrilled to have you with us it
is a toll-free number to jump in triple
eight eight two five
five two two five uh going into the
break i said we're gonna talk about the
value of teachers
and and john i i know you and i both
agree i mean you want to talk about the
unsung heroes of any society
certainly you can say that teachers are
those and certainly throughout this past
year we've seen teachers have to
make adjustments and pivot like they
never have before and we at ramsey
solutions
we know that you are incredible men and
women and april
is national financial literacy month and
we are celebrating you
with our teacher appreciation giveaway
it's sponsored by mint mobile the
affordable premium wireless provider
it's because of teachers like you that
our foundations and personal finance
curriculum has impacted the lives get
this john
of over 5 million students across the
country
and it's been taught in more than 45
percent of america's high schools
and we couldn't have done this without
you you amazing teachers
so starting today you teachers can enter
to win some incredible prizes like a
five
thousand dollar grand prize or
additional prizes
like one thousand dollars in cash so
don't miss out teachers
go to daveramsey.com slash
teacher that's dave ramsey
daveramsey.com
teacher for your chance to win and
what's fun about this is john is we we
love those teachers we talk about the
teachers but how about we actually talk
to a teacher
who is modeling what we were just
bragging about
and so scott excuse me is on the line in
frankfort
kentucky scott you're on the ramsay show
hey guys how are you i'm super excited
to be here today well we're honored
uh and humbled to talk to you and uh i
want our audience to hear
a little bit more about you so you're at
franklin county high school
in frankfort kentucky which is a public
school 900 plus kids enrolled there
and how long have you been a teacher
scott i have
i've been at the high school level for
over 20 years wow
and uh how long have you been teaching
our foundations uh
curriculum i started teaching the
foundations in 2003.
my journey with that actually started in
2002
the curriculum was offered through our
church and my wife decided that we
should go
um and to be honest with you i you know
i didn't really know a lot about it we
were doing the normal thing like
everybody else that quote unquote normal
with credit cards and
and car payments and then we went to the
class and it took about two weeks and i
was all in
uh obviously it changed the way we did
it we started working through the baby
steps and then i said my high school
students have got to have this
and i started teaching the high schools
then um in 2003 and i've taught it every
year um i guess now for 18 years
18 years that is unbelievable in it john
yeah tell us you know as a high school
teacher i was a high school teacher at a
public high school in houston for a few
years
we we know that we we often open our
students eyes to different things that
they may have never seen or heard or
experienced before
when you start talking about hey you
shouldn't have a car payment you
shouldn't use credit cards
i mean you basically you're talking a
different language to these students
right
what do they experience when you're
talking through this
well it's really it is very much what
you said i i tell them all the time i
say some of this stuff and you all look
like i got something growing outside of
my head when i say this
but you tell them you don't have to have
a credit card and you tell them you
don't have to have a car payment
and it's it's just not what they hear
it's not what culture tells them it's
not
how most of them live honestly uh so it
it it's you know
you're you're fighting that a little bit
but once they get into it and they begin
to see
you know hey this you know we do the
budget and we talk about what would your
life be like without that car payment
without that credit card payment
and they begin to realize you know what
they can do with that money and what it
means to them
it's really eye-opening and for me
personally one of the neat things that i
got to do because
when i first started teaching it my wife
and i were working through the baby
steps we were just starting that process
and
i got to share you know our struggles
and our victories and the real life way
with them as they did that with me
uh and it's just as i did that you know
they said well you can do this stuff and
you know and teachers you know i'm just
not a complaint teachers don't make
you know a great salary they all know
that and to show them that you can do
that
on you know what teachers make and
there's no reason for them not to be
able to do that because a lot of them
are going to make more money than than i
do which is awesome for them
uh it's just really awesome and it's
hard to describe i think
i think it's hard to under to overstate
the impact it's had
on my students and their families that's
so amazing
if you're joining us here on the ramsey
show we're talking with scott and
he is a teacher at franklin county high
school in frankfort kentucky he's been
teaching our
foundations and personal finance class
for
18 years been sharing that curriculum in
the classroom and you know scott
i know that teachers get in it for
influence
you get in it because you love
instruction and the results you want to
see is influence and you just mentioned
that it's just really hard to
overstate the impact give us a story
that sticks out in your mind
in your time with these students of a
real success story that you just say
wow that that felt good to see that
result
well and i'll give you two very briefly
and i think it's important to understand
this can have an immediate impact
uh i had a student even with coving and
virtual and all the things that we've
had to do this year
i had a student come in he'd been in the
class two months
and came in and very had this big smile
on his face and walked up to him and
said hey i bought a card and i paid cash
for it oh
and so you know i probably wouldn't have
done that if i hadn't had the class and
i'm like
how awesome is that you know because i
have high school students have car
payments um
when they come into the class now and
and he was just so excited because he
had done this and learned what it meant
to do that
and then i have a student i had in class
probably 15 years ago and i'll still see
her out in the community
and she'll point to him she always
points to me and says still no credit
cards still no debt
doing well wow and so that's that
long-term impact
that you get um for them and you know
again now and i'm old i'm old now what
that means but
you know i've had students long you know
been at it long enough where students
have their own kids
and they're beginning to teach their
kids this stuff and convey that to them
so you've really you know i've gotten in
you know the curriculum's got an impact
multiple generations at that point
i love that what is it what does it feel
like man when you
again you you aren't going to see that
that direct deposit every month
and get value from that right we all
know yeah you're not going to
hop in a lexus after the work day and
drive home right
we know these things but man
it's friday night the your house is
quiet and you start thinking about
the multiple generational legacies that
you've impacted because you keep doing
it every year you keep doing it and
these students keep looking at your
cross side and you keep doing it
tell tell the audience what that feels
like man to be a part of generational
change in that way
it's really hard to describe when you
have students come back to years later
and say hey you know i remember this i
remember that or i did this or i did
that
uh it's hard to describe that feeling
and as my wife and i worked through the
baby steps and we did that i had that on
you know on the family into and what
it's done for us and we're so
appreciative of that and
the way it changed our outlook on things
and then when you
you get to convey that to your students
it's nice to be in the classroom and
have that
but man when they come back and tell you
hey you know
look at what i've done or look at where
i am and look i've got i don't have the
student loans and
you know i don't have the car payment
and i've been able to do this and
you know last um i guess it was last
year i had a student who
just you know took the class for the
first time and really thought me on some
things to be honest with you because his
mom and dad had different things and
whatnot and
you know the credit cards and whatnot
and then he had a he went out and had
um he went out and did a bunch of work
over the summer and walked in and bought
him a new macbook and a new iphone that
he'd say for and paid cash for both of
them
and you know and that's just not
something he would have done and
um his parents you know even contacted
me and said you know
you know we would have bought it for him
but he wanted to do it on his own
i love it well scott i gotta tell you on
behalf of dr john dolone
uh and our entire uh ramsey education
team the entire company you know
we can't do what we get to do without
people like you partnering with us and
you decided 18 years ago
to make an investment in this curriculum
and invest in the lives of your kids and
you've just shared a few stories
of some things they've been able to buy
but i think your true legacy will be
the lifestyle they leave and the kids
that aren't stressed to their
lives and the marriages that stay
together man i just think generational
impact
so scott we applaud you we appreciate
you
and teachers don't forget go to
daveramsey.com
teacher you deserve it sign up to win
some real cash
all right hey we got to get out of here
i want to thank our producer james
childs our associate producer kelly
daniel
my colleague dr john deloney and you
america this is the ramsay show
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsay advice in
their life
let them know about the ramsey call of
the day podcast
it's a quick hit of advice about life
and money in
under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day podcast
wherever you listen to podcasts
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio
this is the ramsey show it's where
america hangs out
to have a conversation about your life
your money your relationships your
work and i'm ken coleman i'm host of the
ken coleman show which is a part of the
ramsey solutions network
and that show focuses on doing work
that you love purpose in your life and
your work
and of course money and relationships is
a part of that
triple eight eight two five five two two
five is the phone number
triple eight eight two five five two two
five if you like to join the
conversation jump in
let's go to jim who is on the line in
fort smith
arkansas jim how can i help oh not too
i'm doing good how are y'all um i have a
business
that i have started up i've had it for a
couple years now
but it's really growing it's actually
growing a lot quicker than i expected to
and i also work a full-time job so it's
really sad
um and i'm curious how much i should
keep putting into the business where
should i stop
at okay great give me a little bit more
of a financial snapshot
and let's first talk about what type of
business it is what type of business
is the side hustle it's a lawn care
service so
five likes i've had a couple years i'm
now i'm getting up close to 30 clients
i'm gonna get called every day so i'm
staying pretty busy um we've been on the
baby steps since
a little over a year now um and we're
we've been four five six
good you know we're there that's great
okay full-time job my wife worked
wow how many hours a week are you
working in the
lawn care business in addition to your
uh day job shall we call it
um 12 10 to 12 hours a week is where i'm
at i'm getting to the point i'm probably
closer to like 16 to 20. is it just you
right now it is just me i'm getting i'm
almost to the point where i'm gonna have
to have
some help yep but i'm not sure if i'm
ready to go over that to get to help if
i'm i'm still wanting to stay
god myself well that that's the answer
then we got it that's how we answer the
question that you asked how much should
i invest back into my business
how much are you making and i'm not
saying how much you're paying yourself
how much gross income
are you making in the lawn care business
well like i said this is the first month
of a few years i've had it that it's
really picked up i've been pushing hard
on this month
right for the month of april i should
clear about six thousand okay and then
what are you
what are you making uh what's your take
home i should make
i should make bring home six thousand
that's your bring home from your day job
yeah my brain no no from my day job i'm
sorry my day job
i make uh 52 a year and my wife makes
about 65 a year
okay so the goal is to eventually walk
away from your day job where you're
making fifty three thousand a year and
no oh it's not not oh no sir no sir i
enjoy my day job
all right i'll keep my day job until i'm
ready to retire okay so then why did you
ask me how much you should invest do you
mean how much you shouldn't save
in your lawn care business how much how
much should i invest in it i mean i'm
i don't ever want to leave my day job
but i could see myself having a
full-time crew
doing it while i'm at my day job too and
me doing it on the wall today okay so
when i heard invest i thought this was a
financial
question you're saying how much time
yeah
yeah how much time and how much money
should i invest and keep growing the
business even though i'm not going to do
it full-time
okay great okay uh well the amount of
time you should invest comes down to you
and your wife have a conversation in all
your different deals so you've got your
day job right
and and so you go and right now you're
putting in you said about 12 hours 12 to
15 hours a week i think that's probably
your max
if i understood your emotion around that
is that correct
yeah it's it's getting there good so
let's just keep it there
i would just keep it there that's what
you should invest in leading
that business now right now you're doing
all the work okay
so that's good income you're bringing
home i would start
i would start talking to people right
now uh who
who run some successful lawn care
businesses i would be having lunch with
them
just to kind of run some ideas by them
on the numbers but i think you should
start to try to replace yourself
maybe three to four hours a week let's
just kind of baby step our way into that
as well
okay and just go okay i'm gonna i'm
gonna turn over this particular
you said you had 40 clients i think you
said so i'd turn over five
yeah i'm i'm at 30 right now but i pick
up my big my big money making flowers
that's where i make the majority of my
money well then what i would do is
i would start trying to peel off some of
the lawn care work to somebody else who
can
cut grass and then what i would do is to
start to look to train somebody who
loves the landscape
architecture the design the flower beds
because that's where the big money is
and so you kind of bring somebody along
and you train them
i mean you you need to start replacing
yourself that's what you need to be
investing in
and again um the more money the more
people you have to do work the more
money you can make
so i think the investment is the time
investment stays where it is
the financial investment would be
retaining almost
all of your earnings over the next three
to six months because you don't have to
live off of it
and i would be thinking about putting
some money in the bank so i'm going to
start hiring some hourly people
to replace me and the goal is to stay at
12 to 15 hours for you but where you're
really just running the business
and recruiting people and bringing them
in that would be my goal
and i think that you can do that and
it's not risky
but you just slowly replace yourself and
once you do that
now you've got this great business and
and the day job
because that's the goal yeah yeah yeah
you got
it yeah that's the goal that's it take
your time and here's the thing i hear
this a lot from
entrepreneurs let me let me kind of get
ahead of this a little bit
because i think you're going to feel
this at some point i took a call at one
of our entree leadership events last
year
not a call goodness i'm on the radio
right now i took a call i took a
question
and the guy said i can't find good
people i can't find good help he said to
me
and he was a young guy about 25 26 and
he was running a ranch
and i said to him i said what do you
describe the kind of person
that you are the work you love and and
why you do the work you do so you begin
to describe it i said
are you telling me there aren't any
other young bucks out there in your in
your zip code and your county and your
area of the state that love working with
animals loved being outdoors all day and
he had this big smile on his face
because he began to realize wait a
second i need to go find
somebody like me who actually loves this
work
and so what you need to do jim is start
to go hey who are some people that like
designing flower beds who are the young
people out there it doesn't have to be
young person middle age
let's just get the word out tell
everybody we know about the work
that i'm doing and let's see who raises
their hand
and learn how to interview them and say
hey this is what's involved do you
love doing this kind of work and and do
we have the the basic skill set that i
can kind of mold and train
and then when you do that you teach them
you let them do it you evaluate them
teach them some more
give them more keep evaluating and you
stay as the face
of the business you're signing up the
clients and you become really the ceo
and you begin to train the process you
begin to replicate yourself
but don't overthink this jim and any
other entrepreneur out there
the key is to replicate yourself replace
yourself
and when you do that that's how you
scale
you don't have to go hire a bunch of
people at once and take on
all kinds of responsibility and payroll
a little bit at a time he has 30 clients
may jump let's
peel off five kill off another five get
somebody else doing those things
and slowly and steadily we grow the
business
slow and steady always wins the race
remember that there's a temptation to
run
really really fast all right don't move
my colleague dr john deloney joins me
for the rest of the hour
next this is the ramsay show
[Music]
hey folks i got a great option to help
you pay for your education
the army national guard the army
national guard believes you
are the next greatest generation because
you have proven that even in adversity
that you have what it takes to succeed
that's why they offer benefits like
tuition assistance
career training and a paycheck to help
you avoid debt
no matter what your goals are the army
national guard can help you
get there visit nationalguard.com to
find out more
[Music]
so
[Music]
the ramsay show continues from our
ramsey solutions studios in nashville
thrilled to have you with us
it is a free call if you want to jump in
on the conversation about your life
your money your relationships your work
hey you want to make some more money
move up the ladder
uh you've got a toxic work situation
come on jump in triple eight eight two
five five two two five you got a money
question
jump in dr john dolone ken coleman with
you
this hour triple eight eight two five
five
two two five if you've been paying
attention to the real estate market this
last year you've noticed the competition
out there
is high in part because inventory is at
an all-time
low so when inventory is low it just
means there's more buyers
buying than sellers selling and that
just cranks the whole thing up
buyers want to snag the right house
sellers won't accept the right offer
and so folks you can get hurt this is
not amateur hour
low inventory is here to stay to win in
this market need a pro that's why we
find vet
and endorse top real estate agents
across the country and we call them
endorsed
local providers to help you buy or
sell our agents have years of industry
success
and they're going to help you win here's
the good news you can instantly connect
with an
endorsed local provider in your area
today
just text the word house to 33789 that's
house
text that word to 33789 to get a ramsay
trusted agent near
you that's house text that to 33789
all right let's go to amy who joins us
next in birmingham alabama amy
how can we help hey guys thank y'all so
much for taking my call
um my question is uh partly about
financial success um
i am trying to figure out kind of how to
get um
on the top side of the hill rather than
the bottom which is where i feel like
i'm at
um i'm thinking about selling my car
because i owe
um roughly 14 000 on it and um
that's about what it's worth maybe you
ever take a hundred dollars and
um so i'm fine with selling it to get
rid of the payment
but i really don't have savings to be
able to put out for like
a thousand dollar car just to get from a
to b
and so i kind of feel like i'm in a sex
situation
um and on top of that
my husband is the only one who works
because i'm in nursing school
and uh his job that he's out right now
we're honestly just making ends meet
there's nothing
left over at the end to put towards a
car there's nothing
there's nothing extra and he's trying to
pick up extra work or work as many hours
as he can
but it just it doesn't seem to be
helping um the extra hours he's working
so
i kind of feel like i don't really know
what to do all right give me a snapshot
is the car you're only debt or what is
your total debt
situation uh total debt
i'd say prob we're probably somewhere
we're less than 20 for sure
um my car i have like 11 1200 on a
credit card
um and then maybe 600 here and there
um two places i can think of so really
not much
okay so i don't know how long you've
been engaged with the ramsey show or
our organization but we teach the debt
snowball
when you're attacking your debt so
that's the smallest debt
and we attack that and i know you say
there's not much left over
and that's probably true for the rest of
that debt not just the car is that
correct you guys are just
really tight yeah that's
that's great all right so so what let me
just give you kind of our philosophy
here so you know what you need to do and
then we can address how you can get
after it
what you need to do is you said first of
all you need to know all your debt so
before you go to sleep tonight
uh you need to have all of your debt
laid out written down on paper and so
you said you had a couple like 600
so let's say you had one at 500 one at
six and then you mentioned 1200 a credit
card
so you're gonna smallest to largest and
you're going to attack
the smallest debt and so let's say
there's a minimum payment of 50
on the 500 and you do everything to
attack that
then you roll that minimum payment and
then you attack the next one and that's
the debt
snowball and that's where momentum comes
from so that's the process
for how you're going to attack the debt
not not with the car first now
let's talk about your realities how to
increase your income because you guys
need some discipline and we're going to
get you connected to ramsey plus here in
just a moment okay i'm going to have
kelly connect you there for
a free trial of ramsey plus where you're
going to get our
budgeting tools you're going to learn
financial piece and go through that
you'll get the
every dollar budgeting app and then you
get the baby step tracker and the gold
the debt tracker and all that all that
plus more more more more more i'm going
to give you that for free
and you're going to follow it isn't that
true
yeah good all right now john let's talk
about
increasing income what i'm curious about
is do you have any hours in the week
realistically uh to be able to work
while doing nursing school
realistically i probably could squeeze
out
four to six hours and i actually am
hired with ship the grocery
uh grocery company as far as pickup and
all
so i could probably squeeze out four to
six hours okay i'd like you to get
something that shot just shipped and
relied like i'd like you to kind of lock
in on something
and go okay i know i'm getting this
amount of hours and i'm getting this
amount of pay and it's very consistent
that's what i think you need and then
you said your husband's struggling to
find
uh extra jobs i i don't want to sound
cynical but i'm having a hard time
understanding
in birmingham alabama how he's having a
hard time finding just
a couple jobs here and there delivering
something
stacking stuff in a warehouse stacking
shelves at night i'm having a hard time
okay um well to be totally honest about
it um
he's really not on board with all this
um i've been trying for like three or
four years to get him on board with this
and
he you know does it for like a day or
two and then nothing and so it's really
hard
i feel like there's so many layers here
but um he's
i'm kind of encouraging him to stay at
work
extra hours to get more hours and that's
about all i can get from him right now
i what's the deeper issue here
is your marriage in trouble um
yes yes yes and
so what i what i need you to hear is
this plan to get you guys out of debt
works it's worked for millions and
millions of people
but if only one of you is on board it
won't work
and if one of you is all in you're gonna
end up getting frustrated and
frustration is gonna lead to
anger and that anger is gonna lead to
resentment and resentment is the ash of
a relationship
it's over and so
you are getting to the end here of every
month and you've got nothing left
and you're a full-time nursing student
which is hard right
yeah what what about this situation is
your husband not experiencing with you
does he not care put on a credit card
we're having fun life's great
yes he's just he's a free spirit which
is fine like i'm the nerd and that's
fine
um but he he grew up with a lot of debt
and
credit cards and payments were fine and
normal and
have you sat down
across a table and looked him in the eye
and said here's how
unsafe and untethered and unsecure i
feel
or have you nibbled around the edges and
said hey how about a few more hours
which can really quickly go from
encouragement to nagging from nagging to
complaining
and now he's off making sure he's got a
different world
because he can't handle you right has he
has he heard you uh both
i've done both um we've done counseling
and um
i don't want to linger this phone call
no there's other people but um we
actually
did go through the program like two
years ago got completely debt-free
and then it just
there's a lot of dishonesty and lack of
trust there and
two he's kind of got two lives going on
and so it's
there's a lot happening but we have a
son and so i really want it to be good
for him
you know future well so here's the deal
um
by just wallpapering over this stuff
there's gonna be tension in your home
you've got two lives your husband's got
two lives and here's what's gonna happen
with that little boy
your little boy is going to absorb this
relational tension
he's going to make it his fault and he's
going to spend the rest of his life
trying to solve it
and he's going to solve it in a million
different ways
and so for you because you deserve this
for your husband because he deserves
this and for this little boy
you've got to throw the flag turn all
the lights on the stadium
at your at your home and say this
marriage is on life support and we gotta
act
now and i know we went through fpu once
i know we went to counseling before
we've got to get into some intensive
relationship counseling today
this weekend starting monday because
this thing's on its last legs and people
are about to start making some decisions
that they
might not be able to recover from you're
worth this amy your husband's worth it
and so is that little boy
okay this is way bigger than the car now
and here's the good news amy you've done
it once before which means you can do it
again that's the goodness you know what
to do this is all about
it has to stop today this marriage has
to be saved
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back america you are joining the
conversation here on the ramsay show i'm
ken coleman joined by my colleague
john deloney and we are taking your
calls triple eight eight two five five
two two five
triple eight eight two five five two two
five you wanna talk about life
and every angle we are here for you
let's go
back to the phones susan is on the line
in atlanta georgia susan how can we help
hi guys thanks for calling
if you might have some advice um
my mother is 93 almost 94.
she's got alzheimer's she's an assisted
living has been
for several years her body is fine she
is still going strong my
other siblings are all older than me my
three older brothers they've all retired
and i'm trying my best to get retired
within the next couple of years
problem is mother's running out of money
and she's probably going to be out of
money by the end of the year
my brothers think that we should all
pitch in
and help her to maintain her dignity
and her lifestyle at this assisted
living home they take very good care of
her
the problem is for us to do that we've
each got to pitch in
to supplement the social security that
she has
about fifteen hundred dollars a month
each
yes oh
so the other alternative from what the
um senior provision caretakers are
telling us
is she would have to go to a medicaid
bed and we just can't do that
i mean we love our mother we want her to
be comfortable we want her to have
dignity
for the rest of the days of her life and
being that she's got the memory issue
we don't think that we can have her come
live with one of us
which it would be me um
because the in-home health care
from what we're told is even more
expensive
than being in an assisted living place
like she's at
do you have the money
i won't be able to retire i do have the
money i just won't be able to retire and
with mother being as healthy as she is
she could live to be a hundred she could
live to be more than a hundred
um the chances of that happening are
very small but that you're getting way
ahead of yourself
so you've presented two to
two issues that are at odds with one
another and then you've got to make a
choice
um you want to maintain a really
expensive a really nice
home for your mom and you won't be able
to retire
and you want to retire it sounds like
you just have an
a a simple yet very difficult choice to
make
okay all right well that
does that make sense i know what we're
being told how long how long is she
being diagnosed with the alzheimer's
it um since she was about
89 and how old is she now
uh 93 should be 94 next month and
have you have you and your brothers have
y'all looked at every of
options other facilities around have you
had conversations with social worker
who's gonna
can help you navigate some of these
things because this idea
number one i don't like the threat of
well if you don't do that if you don't
pony up the money we're gonna have to
send them to that bit
that's a scummy that's a move
that's a move and it's something that
none of us want to do i mean you know
but
i've had a family member at in a
medicaid bed and she was taken care of
incredibly it was wonderful experience
and so well that's good to hear i don't
know
every place is different but the fact
that they're gonna pitch that to you
sounds like a move it sounds gross
and so i would be on the phone with
every other home
in the area places that are closed
places that are not close
because i understand with all my heart
this desire to
retain dignity i get that i understand
the desire to
want to retire but if you've made the
commitment i'm not going to do that to
my mom then you've answered your own
retirement question
and you got to let that dream go and
then be about honoring your mom and the
way you want to do it
i don't necessarily think it's going to
be social security plus
1500 times however many brothers and
sisters you got
i also don't think that it has to be i'm
going to pitch in for my mom whatever
the solution ends up being based on what
john
said and i can't retire that's that's
not it's a false narrative
you can retire you just may not be able
to retire as quickly as you'd like to
or maybe you're going to sell your house
and you're going to buy a smaller house
or you're going to get rid of your car
payment or you're going to figure out
what it's going to look like but when
you box yourself into it
well it's this or that then the world
gets real bleak real quick
and there's almost always other options
yep
i agree i think you got to do some more
digging and the brothers need to step up
as well i i'm feeling john i can hear it
in her voice this feels like
they're putting a lot of this on her and
that's it's time for
for an all hands on deck meeting triple
eight eight two five five two two five
is the number let's go to los angeles
california where andrew joins us andrew
how can we help hi kim jong-un
thanks for taking my call you've both
been a huge encouragement over the past
few years
thank you what's going on so
i'm really glad to be talking to both of
you because this question has both a
career and an emotional aspect
so we moved to la a very expensive area
so that my wife can have a close
proximity to her dream job of being a
writer for children's innovation
however we accidentally moved here at
the worst time because the pandemic hit
right after
and most of the companies haven't been
hiring or producing as much content
financially we're still doing really
well just just off my income and our
savings but i'm a total tight wad and it
feels like we're burning a pile of money
each month for a dream that is yet to
take off so the career question is how
do we balance
pursuing a dream job with making smart
money decisions
and the emotional part is how do i hush
the part of my brain that keeps
complaining that we're wasting money
even though i think she has a real shot
of getting that dream job
well i'll i'll just start on the first
part and let john weigh in
uh but i got opinion on both of them
john
both man all right andrew here's the
deal again
it's it's a false choice you've
presented yourself and then asked us a
question based on a false choice
um you guys are burning through savings
and you shouldn't be
um you know right now you've got
an economy in her world that has slowed
way down
and i agree with you she can get it and
i love that you guys made the move but
guess what she needs to be working
multiple jobs right now and she's still
making connections and she's still
writing at night
or really early in the morning but she
needs to be working
to support her dream as well and i'm not
saying that she's not working i'm saying
that this is a
this is a both end here we we pursue the
dream
but we also make smart money decisions
it's not either or it's not how do we
balance going everything to dream and
make good
and make good decisions no we make good
decisions and that might slow down the
pursuit of the dream
covett has slowed down the pursuit of
the dream right now for you
so stop burning through the savings as
quick as possible i don't think that
that's a
that that's some something wrong with
you because you're going i don't want to
burn through our savings that doesn't
make you emotionally distraught it makes
you smart
uh may i weigh in on that just to give
you more perspective
yeah go ahead yeah it's your call yeah
we're uh
we're netting about 170 per year and
we're living on about 60 000
so we're still putting like a hundred
thousand dollars in
savings almost every year okay then your
question is almost ready
more made from a type again this is less
about
us burning through savings and more
about me looking at other places saying
we could be saving upwards of thirty
thousand dollars
in taxes and in rent if we live
somewhere else and it's not
it's not a question of burning through
savings it's a question of
me getting over the fact that yeah we're
spending more than we would somewhere
else
but is that worth it to pursue the dream
okay so did you get in the car and drive
across the country with your wife to
pursue a dream
um not exactly no we
were living in orange county california
right at that time i was
we were weighing whether or not we would
move out of california
then she got a really good job in los
angeles andrew andrew listen listen
we're listening
andrew listen to me this is pretty
simple stuff okay here's the deal
you just said that you were burning
through savings and then when i really
challenged you and he went oh actually
i'm just being really tight and
unreasonable yeah you are you guys are
crushing it
you're living on way less than you make
and you also told us that you believe
your wife is gonna make it so quit
andrew so relax and stay there you guys
are fine financially
this isn't magic here's how you stop
stop
you're obsessing about this and you need
to stop obsessing
hear me say you're doing a great job a
really great job financially
you can't do anymore have some joy in
your life brother it's a choice
stay the course your wife's gonna make
it unless you drive her crazy in the
[Music]
meantime
[Music]
[Music]
this is the ramsey show and we're
thrilled that you have joined the
conversation i'm ken coleman joined by
my colleague
john deloney the phone number to jump in
triple eight eight two five
five two two five that's triple eight
eight two five
five two two five our scripture today
psalm 100
verse three know that the lord is god it
is he who made us
and we are his we are his people the
sheep
of his pasture our quote of the day from
albert einstein greatest head of hair in
the history of science
he said in the middle of every
difficulty
lies opportunity and i think he's right
i 100 agree it's pretty good you know
that's a
you know for a guy that was brilliant
with numbers and all that that right
there
that's that's all mindset stuff right
there you know learn how to just dig
into the difficult thing
what can i get out of this because you
know why
the science is the the active act of
being less wrong
and so when you have a great scientist
they most of their time is spent
yeah being dealing with being wrong yeah
and then using that as fuel for the next
attempt at being less wrong that's the
beauty of it and so
when you hear these quotes from these
scientists it sometimes feels off-kilter
because he's einstein
einstein knows every day was a battle
with being wrong
and being wrong and being wrong and then
getting back up and going again
love it triple eight eight two five five
two two five let's go north of the
border beautiful montreal
canada is where veronica joins us
veronica how can we help
hello thanks hi guys i'm so grateful to
talk to you
so i have a quick question um here we go
i'm 31 years old i'm currently single
no children um i've been working
in labor relations for five years
my current salary is 55 000
however i'm starting a new job in three
weeks
and i have a significant salary increase
my new salary would be
92 000. whoa hey yes i know i know
congratulations veronica don't just fly
by that one
wow yeah i know so here's my question
i want to know where to what to do with
that
um extra money that i'll be having i
have no debts
i currently own two condos so one that
i'm renting out right now and another
one that i'm currently
living in um i have a car that it's a
100
paid full and i'm at baby step number
four
because i am saving 15 of my annual
uh salary oil income in my um 401k
so the condo that i'm renting right now
i have
99 000 left on my mortgage and
um the condo that i'm living in i have a
little bit over 200
000 um as a mortgage so
i want to know i basically want to still
live
on my same um lifestyle current
lifestyle so i don't want to spend
extra money so where should i invest
that extra money that i would get from
my income should i attack my first
mortgage
yes yes yeah okay just
absolutely just absolutely attack it
and you want to pay that off because
you're already investing 15
of your income you have no other debt
except these two condos
so this is like taking on the i mean you
technically have debt you know
we we you know what we say ramsey
solutions is you you can work on the
home
right and and you can be debt-free but
you technically have debt you got
you got two condos one you're living in
the other you're renting so
i would attack the the uh the smallest
condo i'd get after that and pay that
off
and that additional income you've got
you can really uh you can get after that
but you're already
you're already investing and i think
technically you know i think
i i think i would throw everything i'd
i'd probably pause the 15
here because it's she's not debt free i
mean the way we define it
is you got one you're living in the
other room so i would pause
baby step four here okay and i would
throw that income
uh uh plus that the amount you're
investing there plus the additional
income
at that at that house and then sell that
thing
and then whatever you make on it i'd put
it into the one you know
so live in one you get what i'm saying
so i can't remember which one is the one
you're living in is the 99 000 when
you're living in or you're renting that
one
no i'm renting the 99 000 mortgage one
yeah and i'm living in my
200 000 one that i have yet okay so
how much is that condo worth the 99 000
it worked currently the last time i
checked was
about a little bit under 300 000. oh
gosh i'd sell it
sell it sorry yeah you know what to be
honest with you i caught myself
and anybody knows the show's like ken
why don't you tell her this i was just
like stop you you get so much income
and all this you need to sell the condo
right now like put it up today because
it's worth 300 is that what you said 300
it's worth a little bit under 300 000
but what about this idea of
building wealth you're going to build
hold on hold on i know
i just i think i'm brain tired i should
have told you this initially but here's
what you do you sell this thing
okay okay and and so after your
commission let's say you got 180
whatever 190 whatever it's going to be
okay so all of that
money so now you've got that debt gone
and then you put
that into the current condo that you're
living in which you said you owe 200 on
so you're gonna owe
very little very little and then you
still do what i
said well you don't have to now because
you get you're in the baby steps it's
your home
but i would take that additional income
so you don't pause baby step four i told
you the wrong thing
all right okay you sell the condo the 99
000 condo you take the profit from that
dump it all into the 200
000 condo that you're living in you have
very little left
the additional income of the new job all
of that extra
goes into paying off that very tiny
teeny tiny mortgage right right
and you look up and you're debt free
yeah yeah and then you're really
investing a lot of money and you're
really crushing it you're building
wealth so fast you don't even know what
to do with yourself
and you can save up a bunch of money now
buy a condo cash
so that's what you do i'm sorry yes yeah
there you go it's okay i haven't seen it
that way my first idea was just to like
keep both condos
and yes as you said initially i thought
it would have been best to just attack
this 99 000
mortgage and then keep renting it and
live
you know and that would be like an extra
income you know the the rent the monthly
rent once it's paid off
but it is until like i'm gonna throw
something crazy
at you what happens if i don't know
uh i'm gonna make this up off top of my
head maybe a a global pandemic happens
yeah and then your renters just
don't pay yeah i get you you still owe
the bank that money
and what happens when you try to build
generational wealth on one side of a
teeter-totter
the leverage on the other side at some
point comes due yeah
and when you have no mortgage no car
note
no student loans no nothing and you're
absolutely crushing it
with this um new salary you're making
then you look up and three years later
you buy this condo back because the
market will have corrected itself a bit
with cash yeah and then it doesn't
matter if somebody doesn't show up for a
few months because
you're not you're not up against the
other side of a tutor veronica remember
this
you're going to have a 300 000 condo
that's
cash paid for so there's there's you've
invested wisely
so you've got that that's a big egg and
you still got the 91 000 that you're not
even living on so
that's why you do this you do this much
quicker you're going to turn the wealth
building on
at high speed that that way so that's
why and it's your wealth it's not
it's not wealth that you're playing with
that actually owns is owned by somebody
else yeah
thanks a lot guys i really appreciate it
thanks for your
advice and uh take care thank you
veronica love that what a great position
she's in there
in a man it's like you don't need that
you know what it is people go oh it's
that monthly income
until you realize it's really not yours
right now she's got a 300 000
condo paid in full and she's still got
great income still in baby step four
investing the 15
she's just starting to pile it and the
beauty of it is
again for me you wake up that next day
and you don't have a house payment
think about going on a date with your
wife
at midnight and tipping the waitress
your house note
for the next month the your ability to
be
able to be generous and to give like
crazy i love everything about that
picture about going out on a date with
my wife and be able to do that
and and doing that but not at midnight
it's too late no because you know why
why midnight that's very odd
because nobody's working the midnight
shift because they want to oh
people get stuck in those those
those cycles and that's the only shift
they've got i'm going to show up and i'm
going to change somebody's month
i try to tell my kids nothing good
happens after midnight make someone's
life really good
all right i see where you're going i on
the other hand need to be in bed before
10. i'm with you
needing the extra beauty sleep john i'm
with you hey
this is fun thank you pal appreciate you
as always want to thank our producer
james childs our associate producer
kelly daniel
but most importantly we want to thank
you america thank you for listening this
is the ramsay show
[Music]
hey it's kelly associate producer for
the ramsay show
this episode is over but if you heard
about an event product or service and
didn't have a chance to write it down
don't worry we list everything you've
heard about during this episode in the
podcast show notes section
or head over to daveramsey.com and click
dave recommends
thanks for listening
you